hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
habe versprochen wir müssen auch mal
wieder wish machen ja das kam jetzt
relativ lange nicht ich hatte auch nicht
mehr so Bock drauf muss ich ehrlich sein
aber jetzt habe ich durch Euch erfahren
dass wish quasi so ein neues Rebranding
gemacht hat oder was heißt ein neues
rebounding einfach ein re-branding
bricht neue Farbe also wish ist jetzt
wirklich nicht mehr blau sondern grün
zumindest ist Logo neue Philosophie und
vielleicht auch neue Produkte war hier
gerade mal auf der Instagram Seite das
ist jetzt hier das Video was die letzten
gepostet haben wish halt in grün also
ich finde das Logo wirklich nicht nice
muss ich sagen also ich bin jetzt mal
auf die wish App gewechselt muss aber
feststellen dass irgendwie alles fast so
aussieht wie vorher außer vielleicht das
hier jetzt shoppen ist grün das ist
alles gleich naja ich habe keine Ahnung
was das bringen soll also neues Logo und
dieses grüne Zeugs aber gut ich habe mir
trotzdem mal wieder vorgenommen ein paar
wish Produkte zu testen da ist ja
sicherlich was Neues dabei wenn ihr Bock
drauf habt dass das wieder öfter kommt
lasst mir sehr sehr gerne mal ein
Däumchen nach oben da und wir schauen
uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an was ist denn
hier so eventuell neues gibt die
Produkte müssen nicht immer geil sein
sie genau einfach dumm und lustig sein
let's go das habe ich schon mal irgendwo
gesehen ich glaube war das vielleicht so
ein so ein tiktok Trend kann das sein
kommen die will ich haben guck mal
einmal hier bei Express weil hier sind
ja Sachen weil die auch schneller
geliefert werden das ist ja vermutlich
gar nicht so verkehrt wenn man Zeiten
auch mal dann das Video drehen möchte
guck mal und tatsächlich wir haben hier
Apple iPad Mini 1234 in schwarz aber für
189 €, das halte ich für ziemlich teuer
ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal neu
guck mal ist refurbished renoviert genau
als wenn ich das kaufe das hier ist eine
elektrische kabellose Hochdruck
Autowaschanlage sprühwasserpistole ah ja
ja das ist doch genial das muss ich
unbedingt testen guck mal dann kann man
hier wirklich so sein Auto mit Waschen
kommen let's go in den Warenkorb ich
habe da jetzt schon mal reingelegt so
sieht das Ganze aus wirklich erstmal auf
den ersten Blick relativ kompliziert für
mich aber ich gehe da jetzt mal ganz
positiv dran das schaffen wir schon hier
haben wir einmal die Pistole man muss
dazu sagen das ganze ist ja auch in
Deutschland nicht erlaubt sein Auto
selber auf der Straße zu waschen das
darf man ja seit einigen Jahren nicht
mehr aber wir machen jetzt mal für das
Video eine kleine Ausnahme
für 60 Euro finde ich eigentlich jetzt
mit diesem ganzen Zubehör kann man gar
nicht meckern wir kommen glaube ich
Schaum rein oder sowas Ladekabel noch
eine Batterie das Gute ich habe heute
auch ein bisschen Unterstützung von Jan
der hilft mir auch manchmal und der ist
glaube ich technikaffiner als ich auf
jeden Fall und noch ein Schlauch so dann
schauen wir mal ob wir das Ding zum
laufen bekommen sind ja quasi wie Akkus
die man aufladen kann so
das klingt doch schon mal ganz gut ich
glaube man kann es folgendermaßen lösen
das ganze wir haben es jetzt hier mal
bestenfalls zusammengesteckt da ist auf
jeden Fall einiges dabei also preiswert
also hat mich jetzt auch nicht beschwert
wenn so ein Ding irgendwie 80 € kostet
glaube das Dingen kann man zum Beispiel
in Eimer legen und dann schon feiern und
hier kommt halt noch Schaum rein das
kann man noch hier zwischen klemmen und
dann hat man halt eine richtige
handwaschanlage zu Hause wir testen das
jetzt einfach mal und hoffen dass es
funktioniert
sieht ja noch gar nichts zieht das
irgendwie nicht
[Musik]
können wir jetzt schon ein bisschen
stärker vorgestellt aber vielleicht
liegt es wirklich daran dass wir so ein
Kabelsalat haben mit sagen wir gehen
jetzt mal raus und checken das draußen
ab oder mein Auto ist eh schon wieder
dreckig also hier kann man jetzt sehen
das ist schon stärker geht ja ja so
geht's jetzt schon ab das lag am
Kabelsalat oh mein armer Stuhl ist nur
Wasser oh das ist ganz schön viel Wasser
nettes Parkhaus gesucht kommt mal mit da
vorne steht mein Auto hier ist übrigens
das Wasser drin gab nichts Besseres also
ein Eimer hatten wir leider nicht also
gerade drinnen boah ist das finde ich
ging es ja schon ziemlich ab wir haben
auch immer noch Wasser hier im Schlauch
guck jetzt nicht mehr und hier vorne ist
jetzt ein bisschen Spülung drin damit da
auch schön Schaum rauskommt ich hoffe
mal das funktioniert so let's go
[Musik]
hallo das denn jetzt schon wieder Knick
im Schlauch ist nie gut also es ist
schon ein bisschen umständlich das ganze
hier weil der Schlauch halt so ein
bisschen nervt aber jetzt müsste es
gehen
hallo jetzt mach doch mal Dampf hier
guck mal was ist das denn für ein
billigschlauch
die Leute gucken Menschen hier
also fazit von mir wäre jetzt nicht
empfehlenswert 1A sauber also zumindest
leicht
ah naja was soll's so Leute man kann
auch ruhig natürlich auch Saugroboter
kaufen die sind dann nur vermutlich sehr
günstig und auch sehr schlecht habe ich
damals auch schon mal gemacht ich
erinnere mich gerade glücklicherweise
habe ich heute von Dreami den dreaming
bot l10s ultra zugeschickt bekommen den
wir uns mal anschauen werden und schauen
ob das drauf hat das ist schon wieder
einen mördergerät Arsch schwer aber was
da alles dabei ist ist unfassbar so hier
haben wir das gute Teil ihr könnt sehen
dreamie bot LCS ultra ultra klingt ja
schon immer nicht schlecht wir haben
hier einmal Zubehör das ist auch mein
erster Saugroboter von dreamy die haben
mir damals schon mal ein Handstaubsauger
zugeschickt den ich auch immer noch
wirklich sehr sehr gerne benutze das
Ding ist wirklich ultra nice für meine
Wohnung all Action Cam ja der sieht doch
auf jeden Fall sehr clean aus das ist
der Sauger und wir haben hier auch
wieder eine ich seh schon das ist kein
Minikühlschrank das ist eine
Reinigungsstation ich kenne mich ja
mittlerweile ganz gut damit aus wir
haben hier einmal Frischwasser
Schmutzwasser ja das Ding reicht und
wischt gleichzeitig natürlich so jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt wie das Zubehör
aussieht so habe ich mir das auch schon
vorgestellt zwei Wischmops die könnt da
ganz einfach hier drunter Klemmen eins
und zwei dann haben wir hier einmal die
Borsten damit das Ding auch in jeder
Ecke kommt und eine Gummi Bürste das ist
super verfangen sich keine Kabel drin
schaut mal einmal hier rein Leute das
kommt jetzt die ganz Smoot zack
wunderbar das ist wirklich ein tolles
Feature ich hol mal kurz Wasser wir
testen den heute mal hier bei uns im
Büro Flur weil der Büro Flo ist immer so
dreckig wir gehen tagtäglich viele
Menschen durch und es ist irgendwie nie
sauber obwohl hier so ein
Reinigungsunternehmen auch manchmal
tätig ist was ich noch nie gesehen habe
seitdem ich hier drin bin Frechheit okay
Leute der Dream ist installiert was ich
auch noch sagen wollte sehr cool also
wirklich die dicker werden immer krasser
wir haben natürlich die
Reinigungsstation und Frischwasser und
Abwasser aber in der Home Station hier
ist auch eine Absaugfunktion integriert
das heißt der Dreck wird hier in den
Staubsaugerbeutel gezogen also
eigentlich musst du wirklich gar nichts
mehr machen dann würde ich sagen let's
go
okay Leute Felsen ist ultra hat auf
jeden Fall eine vollautomatische
Reinigung das heißt es wird gewischt es
wird gesaugt beides gleichzeitig über
die App könnt ihr das ganze aber auch
individuell gestalten vielleicht dann
nur saugen nur wissen ihr könnt die
Saugstärke einstellen ihr könnt die
wischstärke einstellen wir haben 60 Tage
lang eine automatische Staubaufnahme
Selbstreinigung der Mops natürlich das
heißt der Sauger reinigt sich komplett
alleine und was hier natürlich auch
neues die automatische Reinigungsmittel
Zugabe für schön Geruch und sauberen
Boden ihr könnt beispielsweise auch ein
haustiermodus aktivieren bei den
Haustier habt das ganze wird durch die
KL plus 3D Laser Navigation ermöglicht
wenn zu Hause Gegenstände rumliegen euer
Sauger erkennt das fährt vorsichtig
drumherum die benutzerdefinierten
reinigungsstrategien machen es möglich
auch bestimmte Ecken besonders zu
reinigen durch die Gummibürste müsst ihr
euch keine Sorgen machen dass ich
irgendwelche Kabel eklig verfangen oder
Haare wenn euer sauber über den Teppich
fährt wird das Ganze natürlich
automatisch erkannt Mops werden leicht
angehoben und wischen natürlich nicht
über den Teppich naja blöd Leute check
das Ding ab erster Link in der
Videobeschreibung das hier ist übrigens
der Raum von meinem Kollegen hier der
freut sich morgen kommt er wieder und
denkt sich warum ist das hier so sauber
ist das hier eine Coron Maske die
transparente schutzmasse schützt
effektiv die wiederverwendbare
Schutzbrille und die schutzrequisiten
der aktiven Schutz wie oft wollt ihr
Schutz in einem Satz verwenden ja jetzt
hier so zur corona-zeit wieder wenn
wieder maskenpflicht kommt wer weiß
crazy ja komm bestelle ich mal
das auch eingetroffen auch mit einiger
Verspätung aber ist kein Problem und das
hier ist wahrscheinlich aha corona-maske
also wenn ich damit einkaufen gehe da
gucken mich doch alle an als hätte ich
einen Schaden boah und die Luft hier
drunter puh ach so hier unten soll man
ja atmen können schaut mal hier sind
halt diese Atemlöcher ich muss erstmal
sagen ich bin überrascht über die
Qualität es ist wirklich gar nicht
schlecht verarbeitet alles da bin ich
schlechteres gewohnt ist halt nur die
Frage ist sowas theoretisch gerade in
Deutschland erlaubt ich glaube nicht
weil es ist kein medizinischer Mund und
Nasenschutz und es sieht halt wirklich
es passt oh kann man ein bisschen
verstellen glaube so muss das oder
vielleicht auch so nee ich glaube so
weiß ich nicht finde ich jetzt nicht
sofort vorteilhaft es schlägt auch schon
da sind auch wirklich dann diese Dinger
die einmal Muttis haben hier mit dem
oben so ein Stirnband rum und dann
einfach so ein Glas Ding hier besser
aber die sind ja auch nicht mehr erlaubt
ich sehe euch gar nicht mehr also das
Ding hier fällt gnadenlos durch YouTube
Daumen runter stellt euch mal vor ihr
seid damit im Supermarkt und wisst gar
nicht wo ihr gerade langlauft hallo
hallo und dann findet ihr natürlich auch
nicht die Sachen die auf eurem
Einkaufszettel stehen und dir klingt
auch noch komisch nee also das ist
Quatsch moin moin okay tragbarer man
muss ja erstmal verstehen was das ist
wenn ach so ah das ist ein tragbarer
Ventilator jetzt habe ich es ja ich habe
gerade viel zu kompliziert gedacht in
pink komm wenn schon denn schon den
möchte ich auch noch kaufen
Massagegerät oder Nackenmassage ist
erster Eindruck ist jetzt nicht so gut
also Scheiße naja gut wer weiß
das Problem ist das Teil stinkt erstens
und zweitens ist es gar nicht mehr warm
draußen aber ich zur falschen Zeit
bestellt oder es hat einfach zu lange
gedauert wenn schon denn schon es gibt
drei Stufen 1 2 3 und jetzt legt man das
hier um Hals so dann kann man das ganze
auch so leicht verstellen
ich drehe es mal noch einmal um aber nee
das ist falsch was ein Schrott also das
ist ja wirklich bodenlos der Wind der
daraus kommt man spürt es ganz leicht
ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen wenn
man hier die ganze Zeit so ein leichten
Wind Zug hat das war dann relativ
schnell krank wird oder weil das soll ja
nicht gesund sein deswegen dieses
Produkt Qualität absolut Rotze war jetzt
auch gar nicht so günstig kann ich euch
nicht empfehlen Daumen runter können
auch Kopfhörer sein hierher es geht was
geht aber eine ganz schön also wirklich
wer bestellt denn eine Matratze auf der
er oder sie ernsthaft die nächsten Jahre
schlafen wollen bei wish glaube das
macht doch niemand oder naja scrollen
wir mal schnell weiter ulala also manche
Sachen die mir hier angezeigt werden
sind aber auch nicht Jugendvereine
boxing
reflexball den macht man sich hier im
Kopf und boxt dann dagegen sowas wollte
ich auch schon noch mal testen kaufen
wir boxing reflexball Boxen ist jetzt
nicht so mein Ding aber also glaube ich
zumindest
ich weiß nicht irgendwo habe ich schon
mal so einen tik tok mit so einem Ding
gesehen das macht man sich jetzt hallo
kann man sich jetzt hier wahrscheinlich
um die Stirn schneiden mal gucken wie
meine Reflexe sind Leute wundert euch
nicht über meinen crazy Outfit und jetzt
ähm also das ist das denn das ist ja
auch
ich muss mir noch mal ganz kurz einmal
das Produkt anschauen ja komm schaut
euch das mal an hier das Bild natürlich
kein Boxer
aber okay Leute jetzt hängt dabei ein
bisschen weiter unten und Action
ja so ist schon besser aber mir fehlen
halt irgendwie leider ein bisschen die
Reflex Alter
boah das ist doch unmöglich also ich
fühle mich leicht wie eine Katze es kann
sein dass es Amerik weil ich halt
einfach keinen Boxer bin aber ich würde
schon als wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
abstufen es könnte funktionieren also
man muss halt einfach nur die Skills
haben und die reflexes
ich muss sagen das Produkt kann man
nicht nicht empfehlen für Leute die die
Reflexe trainieren wollen sicherlich gar
nicht so verkehrt auch wenn es bei mir
jetzt erstmal nicht gut aussieht wie
beim Anfänger aber ich bin ja auch ein
Anfänger oh nächstes Produkt was
passiert hier gerade wir haben ja auf
jeden Fall eine ja echt große äh hier
Puppe ne für 1120 € crazy Digger also
ich muss sagen so ein paar Sachen hier
sind mir tatsächlich neu die habe ich
noch nicht gesehen aber das meiste kenne
ich irgendwie schon was ist das hier
Mikrowellen Nudeln
abtropf-atte Fakt was rechteckiges
Küchensieb für Nudeln Macaron sowas noch
nie gesehen und dann kann man dann
Nudeln drin aufbewahren ja komm keine
Ahnung warum nicht ne kann man doch nie
was mit falsch machen einfach mal
bestellen nicht so lange labern hier
Pipapo hier ist das revolutionierende
Nudel abgießkit was soll das noch mal
bringen mikrowave pastacutter make more
of your Micro Wave also ich benutze
eigentlich immer so ein Ding hier aber
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal ich das
ganze Ding missverstanden das ist mir
neu also hiermit soll man Nudeln in der
Mikrowelle kochen können ich mache das
natürlich immer bei mir im Topf und dann
kann man das direkt abgießen die Soße
hinzugeben und muss halt gar keinen
Teller nehmen also rein theoretisch
gedacht mist ich habe keine Mikrowelle
naja ich löse das schon irgendwie
interessant und hier steht auch direkt
so die Zeiten drauf z.B Spaghetti muss
man nur 10 bis 12 Minuten kochen aber
Penne 11 bis 13 Minuten dumme Frage wird
das auch im Ofen gehen Leute wir schauen
einfach mal mein Backofen hier geht bis
250 Grad das heißt es ganz solche auch
ohne Probleme im Backofen funktionieren
können so jetzt erstmal basteln tun und
ja wollte ja eigentlich schon reichen
das ist jetzt auch warmes Wasser dann
dauert es nicht so lange den Ofen habe
ich hier schon mal angemacht der heizt
schon ein bisschen vor übrigens Leute
das jetzt immer so wenn ich Produkte gut
finde und ich die auch auf Amazon finde
verlinke ich euch das immer in der
Videobeschreibung weil ich habe jetzt
auch so ein Amazon Shop könnt ihr mal
abchecken wenn ihr wollt genau aber wir
packen jetzt erstmal Nudeln rein komm
nehmen wir hier mal was ist das denn
Penne da stand der Penne dauert glaube
ich 13 Minuten müssen heute gar nicht so
viele sein weil ich habe eben auch als
Mittag gegessen aber so ein bisschen
Nudeln jetzt schon noch essen deswegen
kommen ist wirklich die Frage ob das
klappt ich bin echt gespannt ist das
jetzt dumm was ich hier tue nein es muss
funktionieren ey ich bin wirklich so
dumm ich habe mir schon gedacht das kann
doch nicht gut gehen aber das hätte ich
jetzt nicht erwartet ich traue mich gar
nicht dass euch jetzt zu zeigen
eigentlich gerade weil es ist mir auch
peinlich aber ich will hier auch nichts
faken deswegen kommen ja ich bin ein
bisschen dumm okay dazu sage ich jetzt
mal nichts die haben zwar leicht gekocht
aber das außen rum auch
kippen nein ey komm da müsste mir
zustimmen ein bisschen unnötig ist das
Ding schon jeder hat doch einen Topf zu
Hause also leute passt mal kurz auf so
sollte das eigentlich aussehen ja und
ich habe es natürlich nicht hinbekommen
bin rein Wasser rein habe ich auch
gemacht dann kommt das ganze in die
Mikrowelle
für 13 Minuten anscheinend was ich sehr
lang finde in der Mikrowelle schmilzt es
nicht aber ich habe den Fehler gefunden
und ja ich bin dumm ich weiß ich bin
dumm aber sind jetzt auch nicht wieder
gut machen da sieht das jetzt ja ganz
gut aus können das ganze jetzt natürlich
rausschneiden aber so bin ich nicht
anscheinend funktioniert ich wollte euch
nur sagen den Ofen viel zu heiß gemacht
ich habe den auf 200 Grad gedreht eine
Mikrowelle ist wohl nur 80° heiß dann
kocht das Wasser zwar nicht aber
irgendwie garen diese Nudeln doch wäre
für mich eh nichts ich mache Nudeln
weiter im Topf das Ding ist scheiße und
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
Produkt und ich hoffe ihr nehmt es mir
nicht übel viel Spaß und ich bin
wirklich so dumm oh was ist das denn
nature Insektenschutznetz gegen Apfel
okay gut ich habe keinen Apfelbaum im
Garten ich habe nicht mein Garten okay
ich bin hier jetzt wirklich schon eine
Weile am scrollen so wirklich was ist
das hier Alter das sieht ja crazy aus
laufen wir einfach mal so Leute hier
haben wir jetzt das 4D RC ja ist ein
Auto
hyperactives dann natürlich jetzt nichts
für mich so persönlich aber keine Ahnung
für Kinder oder man kann es ja trotzdem
mal checken weil ich war früher auch
immer sehr interessiert an solchen
angesteuerten Autos und für 30 Euro oder
was ich da bezahlt habe kann man ja
nicht meckern vielleicht ist das ja gar
nicht so schlecht erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an diese bionicles von früher
halt von Bionicle von wish bestellt ja
ich habe mich schon gedacht hier fehlen
jetzt wahrscheinlich Batterien wieso ist
das so immer ist hier so eine scheiß
Schraube noch mit drin das heißt ich
brauche jetzt erstmal noch ein
Schraubenzieher so Leute jetzt bin ich
immer aufs Auto gespannt oh das geht ja
schon an Moment chill mal kurz ja ja ist
ja gut tut erster Eindruck ist auf jeden
Fall
eher billig boah
ja ist gut hallo
ich weiß nicht ob es jetzt so rutschig
ist auf dem Boden oder ob die Lenkung
halt einfach nicht so gut funktioniert
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich fand es
witzig mir hat Spaß gemacht war jetzt
auch nicht so teuer ich finde es okay
ist halt so typische Kirmes waren also
Sonnen könnte man auch auf der Kirmes
beim Lose ziehen gewinnen aber okay also
kein absoluter Daumen nach unten da gab
es schon schlimmere Sachen Musik ab
[Musik]
ja Leute das war's mit dem ersten wish
Video nach langer Zeit von mir ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen und ihr hattet Spaß
beim anschauen falls ja lasst mir sehr
gerne Daumen nach oben da abonniert den
Kanal und für weitere Parts Daumen nach
oben halt wäre nicht schlecht ich habe
mir echt Mühe gegeben ich hoffe das hat
man gemerkt und ja Leute wir sehen uns
haut rein bis denne ciao